does size matter or is it more about  motion in the ocean  you know the motion the ocean thing is  really silly because it's really about  the guy the connection the intimacy the  trust the feeling it's not about either  it's women focus so little on the penis  in general we just want you to be a good  dude because you can be with a dude  that's smaller not even that hot but the  connection was so good the nbc is so  good so  um size is great for when you're in that  situation because then you get the  paycheck but oh size of the paycheck  motion in the ocean is such a weird size  the size of the wallet is more important  than the size of the penis  i would say so until there it is